le 18 mai prochain à cheuvreux se
déroulera à l'éco festival un événement
lié au développement durable mais qui
permettra également d'assister à une
dizaine de concerts bonsoir justin
repart ce vous êtes responsable
artistique et communication sur ce
festival et bonsoir à delphine karwassa
vous êtes responsable partenariats le
slogan de ce rendez vous faire pousser
les grandes idées quel est l'objectif
derrière tout ça de cette initiative
alors l'écofestival en fait on l'éco
festival en fait qu'est ce que c'est ça
désigne en fait un festival qui
s'organise avec la contrainte d'intégrer
en fait des contraintes
environnementales dans toutes danses
l'organisation toute la journée par
exemple par exemple alors tout on peut
citer par exemple comme comme éco
festival les plus connus par exemple où
il avait raynaud cabaret vert donc
aujourd'hui nous on se fixe trois
critères qui nous permettent de dire que
aujourd'hui on en est qu'au festival
le premier critère donc c'est les
transports on a mis en place une navette
gratuite entre la gare rer saint de
saint rémy les chevreuse et notre
festival
on a également mis en place un
dispositif de covoiturage sur internet
deuxième critère donc la restauration on
proposera au public une restauration bio
et local on va également servir nos
boissons dans des gobelets consignables
qui seront réutilisées pour pour les
éditions suivantes est donc troisième
critère sensibiliser le public aux
enjeux du développement durable
donc avec la participation de
partenaires associatifs de partenaires
également locaux mais également des
entreprises qui vont venir présenter
différentes problématiques donc par
exemple le réchauffement climatique
l'alimentation locale la biodiversité à
travers notamment un stand sur les
abeilles mais également donc
la valorisation des déchets ménagers et
industriels est également le commerce
équitable
voilà ce qu'il y aura bien évidemment
ces concerts on va en parler tout à
l'heure mais il ya avant tout des
ateliers et des stands d'informations
voilà afin d'en savoir beaucoup plus
vous l'avez dit surtout cesser ces
questions de respect de l'environnement
c'est plutôt un public plus jeune que
vous visez est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que justement ces jeunes sont
déjà conscients de ces différentes
problématiques parce qu on en parle
depuis des années aujourd'hui ça fait
partie du quotidien le respect de
l'environnement tout à fait alors
aujourd'hui c'est quand même quelque
chose qui qui dont tout le monde parle
nous on a vraiment envie de rappeler ce
qui existe et de montrer des nouvelles
choses des choses qui sont moins connus
notamment par exemple tout ce qui est
pollution des matériels informatiques
passé quelque chose aujourd'hui dont on
parle très peu et on a envie aussi
sensibiliser enfants parce qu'il
sensibiliser les enfants pardon parce
qu'on pense que c'est vraiment un public
aujourd'hui qui qui est sensible à ça
notamment on veut mettre en place des
grands jeux sur sur le festival il y
aura des animations toute la journée
c'est la septième édition de ce festival
tout à fait les cons festival alors vous
pouvez faire des précédentes éditions
alors en fait nous on est on est ici la
promotion de sa chance à chaque fois et
voilà est-ce que celui à l'université de
leur fête c'est un projet du master
management en dessous qualité et conduit
d'affaires de l'université de saint
quentin est donc cette année c'est dans
le cadre de notre projet de fin d'études
de monter ce festival
et tous les ans il ya une groupe de la
promotion qui reprend le projet mais
j'imagine qu'un échange avec la
promotion preuve voilà d'emplois dans
une présentation de ce qu'ils ont fait
ou vous nourrissez un petit peu d
expérience d des sources et voilà
exactement ont été dits un petit peu
comment ça s'était passé pour eux alors
l'an dernier ça a été fait à la salle de
concert lac et à saint germain en laye
donc voilà que nous fait un retour ils
nous ont donné des conseils sur les
partenaires a contacté sur sur les
évidemment sur le concert parce qu on
est aussi novice dans l'organe à ce
concert donc ça a été très utile très
utile pour nous dès qu'on sort justement
il ya deux parties dans cette soirée une
partie gratuite à partir de 14h partir
de 21h ce sera payant
il ya des têtes d'affiché qui viendra
participer oui on a au total huit
groupes d'artistes donc de 14h à 21h
on a tous styles de musique que ça passe
aussi bien
jazz au rock pop rock on est même à la
fin donc justement un peu le clou du
spectacle qui est dj dee nasty
donc voilà renommée nationale c'est lui
qu'a vraiment insérer le hip hop voilà
en france quelques années déjà le plus
anciens s'en souviennent sans doute ont
effectivement exactement donc on est
vraiment très fier d avoir mais comme
tous les autres vraiment qui monte et
qui sont absolument géniaux les fins il
y aura beaucoup de swing et ce sera ça
mettra beaucoup d'ambiance voilà pour
l'après midi et ensuite pour le soir
c'est un concert de clôture
mais là ce sera sur du reggae on voit
d'ailleurs à l'image de l'un des groupes
un qui participera c'est le groupe haier
reggae saint gaudinois c'est tout elle
avait aussi voulu privilégier mettre en
avant le la richesse locale
bah oui ça faisait partie c'était à nos
critères quand même et donc on l'a dit
pour ceux qui affectionnent c'est le rap
le hip hop l'après midi ce dj dee nasty
qui sera présent la le concert est
gratuit cette fois ci pourquoi il ya une
partie payants une partie gratuite
c'est le but de toucher des publics
différents c'est le but dès la rentrée
des fonds aussi pour l'association parce
qu'il faut le financer ce fait c'est
exactement il y avait deux parties
l'après midi gratuit parce que on avait
des partenaires qui est en des stands
qui vont vraiment les animés et
notamment on voulait toucher comme on
l'a dit tout à l'heure les plus jeunes
et donc tout de suite si on devait faire
payer tout le festival on s'est dit
qu'on allait limiter notre public donc
on a décidé de le faire gratuit pour
l'après midi et donc là il ya des
artistes qui ont accepté donc voilà deux
joué pour cette partie gratuite du
concert et ensuite en revanche bien
évidemment pour les fonds de notre
de notre événement on a décidé de faire
donc une partie un concert gratuit
on parle donc de cet éco festival ça se
déroule le 18 mai si vous venez nous
rejoindre je vous précise que c'est une
association universitaire un qui s'en
occupent vous êtes basé à l'institut
supérieur de management université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
il ya d'autres opérations que vous
organisez donc ça c'est l'événement
phare de l'association
en fait notre association organise
organisé une manifestation pour financer
le projet voilà donc le but c'était
vraiment l'écofestival et sinon voilà
c'est vraiment notre notre unique projet
dont l'importance de réussir vous
attendez pas la même personne alors le
soir on espère 200 voilà voire plus
et puis l'après midi tout dépendra du
temps et tout dépendra aussi de la voilà
la colonne communication vous êtes là ce
soir j'ai lu aussi que vous recherchez
toujours des bénévoles c'est le cas
effectivement moment ou jamais passer le
message oui tout à fait si vous voulez
venir
on vous accueille avec beaucoup de coeur
en plus de ça et bien vous pourrez
parfum comment dire voir le concert
gratuitement voilà le concert du soir de
foire soit gratuit comme ça merci à
toutes les deux d'être venu présenter
cet événement 18 mai à chevreux cet éco
festival des artistes locaux d'autres
reconnu aussi au niveau national seront
présents pour sensibiliser au
développement durable nous poursuivons
la présence de cette suite avec la
chronique échos